[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host styled sake I'm
very excited to be talking about crazy
wisdom we have the founder of the crazy
wisdom podcast joining us Stewart Alsop
hello I'm really excited to be here
thank you so much thanks for coming on
to the show very very pumped we have a
lot to talk about impact you've done 60
of these in a year which is great and
you're kind of doing these like
contrasting areas like will role
distress playing creativity or will role
the spirituality play in technology and
I love that and I love that I'm excited
this is gonna be a little bit of you
know me talking to you about crazy
wisdom and also you're talking me about
the role of that place and simulation
that I'll be I'll be cool to
double-layer its multiple layers yeah
you got a background in bodywork and
tech detect for seven years bodywork now
for three years and so doing this
massage as well and this bodywork this
is kind of like really driving a little
bit more interest towards how that plays
into technology in our world and how we
can maybe harmonize those merged those
things together totally yeah yeah so
check out Stuart's links below to the
crazy wisdom podcast you guys can find
it right down there um let's start with
this you know big history take on
civilization we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what are your current
thoughts on the state of humanity yeah I
mean it's a big question the humanity is
there's kind of that that deals with
perception so like sometimes I wake up
in the day in the day and I'm like I
feel really good and I'm like okay
humanity's gonna go places and we're
gonna we're gonna be able to survive all
the [ __ ] and then other days I'm just
like we're screwed
so it kind of depends on the day that
you ask me today I'm feeling pretty good
about it I mean we we've got a lot going
for us humanities always had problems so
like our evolutionists all started our
primary evolutionary advantage is
problem-solving so so that's what we do
that's what our minds are created to do
and that's why we have hands and fingers
and quarter at the cortical you know it
all started because of these hands
basically in our
double thumbs and like like so I think
Humanity has a lot going for it we also
have a lot of problems and so it seems
that as technology increases that that
is becoming more and more of an issue
and that the problems are becoming
bigger as well as the solutions are
becoming bigger as well and the
opportunities for the solutions so yeah
yeah yeah so maybe at the time of the
wheel or language or art or and if these
first inventions maybe those were the
breakthroughs those were massively
important at those times now it's all
like background music on those things
and now the new things are like all the
threats of potential disaster with
nuclear war with synthetic biology or
artificial general intelligence and now
we have these hands that are maybe
building those the new era of biology
and the new era of AI and stuff with
again these hands those are now the
cutting-edge advances but it does
totally depend on the day you wake up to
idea whatever happened in dreamland or
whatever happened the day before you
8:00 at night or didn't eat at night or
if you had stress last day there's so
many very exercised gratitude you wake
up and you start just being grateful for
being alive all of a sudden the day got
better
yeah yeah yeah and these practices
they're interesting we we're gonna get
into that I'm sure but but these
practices that we can do that we can
change our mindset in the middle of so
we're in a in a you know in a funk and
then we can actually change our mindset
with these practices but then the
question comes up are we avoiding those
negative emotion the negative emotion
States right yeah and I think
potentially the East has through
meditation Buddhism etc has done a
pretty decent job at explaining how you
can still feel that but you can feel
that you're really sad at watching a
very powerful scene of a movie right you
crying about what happened but at the
same time you're in control and you know
you're in control versus not be in
control and letting the emotion control
you I think though that may be one of
the big distinguishers that I can still
be grateful
I can still have control over my actions
nurses being controlled and it's the
yeah I think you put it really well it's
the witness consciousness yeah so you
you step back from the the the cognition
or the intense emotion and you witness
yourself as part of you as being caught
up in that but then you still have this
kind of overarching awareness and then
that awareness what is that you know and
then then it goes into like life and
university types yes ma'am mm-hmm so now
when you did tech for seven years and
they needed bodywork for three and now
you're doing crazy wisdom tell us about
this like is about this transition
between knows and why you've been doing
it totally so you know as in technology
I started a couple companies had a lot
of stressful situations and the last
last company I built was was quite
stressful ended up in a very difficult
situation at the end had two extra
extricate myself from and I was just
kind of like stress was an ever-present
part of my life
and it was I mean it goes back to
childhood had tricky situation growing
up so I was kind of stress has always
been a component of my life and I
thought it was normal but this point it
was like okay so if something needs to
be done you know why am I in this
situation and I started looking for
answers and then so I started to doing a
lot of meditation I had already been
doing yoga for a long time but I went
deep into the practice and as I did more
meditation yoga then became more
significant towards that practice and
then all the meanings of these terms all
changed as well so it's like now I have
like very different view on what
meditation is than when I first started
that and so I found these practices
really helpful for me and so I started
to like do training and and I came bad
was in India I didn't most of my yoga
teacher training in India I did a lot of
10 day but pastina style meditation
retreats and Thailand yeah and then a
whole whole range of different stuff did
my yoga teacher training and then it
came back to the San Francisco where I
would screw up and were and I grew up in
technology like my father's involved in
technology so it's always been an
ever-present kind of thing and I'm like
okay I've got this unique position in
technology and I was very stressed out
and I know a lot of other people are
stressed out so how do I then bring this
component that can also de-stress people
into that and help people kind of find
some calm
amidst the noise and chaos yeah yeah
it's cool that you were born here and
then you went to India in Thailand for a
period after the stressful company
building and to be able to connect
spiritually meditation the practice and
then that you bring back yogi bring back
to the bay and now you kind of see tech
and spirituality and it's in his own new
lens totally three years well and it's
really interesting because if the
history of yoga and meditation is all
wrapped up in globalization as well and
most people don't know that the yoga as
we practiced in the studios today is
only an invention of last hundred fifty
years there was a basically gymnastics
got really popular in Northern Europe
and then the British became popular in
Britain and in the Britain Britain
because they colonized India then
brought that to India started training
the national elite there the nationalist
there and and then they basically
rediscovered their books through
theosophy and through all these
religious kind of new New Age practices
and stuff like that and then melded
together to create what modern postural
yoga is now and then meditation also
happened I'm still not quite clear on
how it happened with meditation and
Buddha and 2,500 years ago is kind of
what the tale is yeah but then but then
the actual practice was lost after
Buddha yes yeah yeah and then in that
picking back up was then transformed
yeah that's right yeah huit the that's
very crazy the British gymnastics bring
to India the strips how to train their
stretch and then train the athletes
resurface the old literature so well and
that was a new that was another strain
too so theosophy I'm not sure if you're
familiar with Madame Blavatsky and
theosophy that was a part of a
spiritualist movement in the 1850s where
there's this religion called
spiritualism where that's where you get
the idea of medium a medium and stuff
like that and so Madame Blavatsky was
this Russian woman who made her way to
Europe and then to America and started
her own religion called theosophy that
didn't take off in America but it took
off like crazy in India and then that
mixed with this gymnastics from from
Britain and combined to create this this
this this weird New Age mixture that
nobody can really pick apart anything
like
and so it's really cool yeah Ron what's
this image you brought up so I can
actually explain it yeah yeah so this is
this is I don't have a good logo yet for
my for my podcast so this is um
Grayson's lips ins logo for this is I
thought I saw crazy wisdoms logo on
iTunes is different it is but I can't
figure out how to change how to put that
into the into the new logo no no this is
lips ins default logo the create the
crazy wisdom logo the crazy wisdom logo
is able to be seen on it's like a mic
with like blue flames yes okay that's
very interesting about how these things
end up coming around and almost like new
features give put in with what's
resurface exactly and then they make new
things to grade books on this our Yoga
body and Yoga body and the roots of yoga
that explains the rise of modern
postural yoga within because there is
also an interesting innovation that
happened in the 9th century in Kashmir
India called tantric with a ke tantric
yoga not neo Tantra which is the
sexually charged form of yoga but Tantra
itself and that also influenced this
rise as well and got mixed in with this
globalization thing because that that
essentially overtook Buddhism and within
within popular contemporary Indian
philosophy and then kind of created its
own Buddhism which is tantric Buddhism
which made it way to Tibet so it's
really fascinating globalization story
but essentially all these practices were
lost from about like I think of 500 BC
until about a 900 AD yeah yeah which is
insane for something to be lost that
loss for that long
you makes me always think about all the
the artifacts that are disappearing from
the planet that we still need to dig up
before they disappear into nothingness
totally yeah because then we can
actually understand where we came from
better hmm okay so this transition as
you're like you're unpacking these
interesting tech bodywork you know
spirituality tech understandings takes
you to interviewing people for crazy
wisdom podcast yep yeah so yeah so so
the the I've experienced a lot of stress
in my life and people have always told
me creative that was creative and I
didn't really understand what that meant
and so I was like okay I'm creative I
like I create stuff some of it hasn't
been working out some of it does work
out I want to understand more about how
other people deal with stress and and
because if you're going to create
something they're stressed there's
always stress there and I think one of
the things I've learned on the show is
that there's always going to be stressed
but suffering is that mind added created
creation that adds an extra layer of of
pain on top of that on top of that
creation so I want to I want because I'm
also very lazy so I wanted to figure out
how to how to create something without
working to are you know in another nice
things that you get to unpack these
wisdoms from other people's lives and to
grate them into your life teach other
people about what you've been learning
mmm they get to hear it this is this is
uh this is my logo at the logo yeah for
crazy wisdom the thumbs-up from Ronnie
okay so so now tell us to keep keep
going with what you've been learning now
with these 60 guests and like stressing
creativity so yeah actually I started
off interviewing people about their
meditation practice because I met inand
stresses vary as the meditation is the
is the practice of working with stress
but then I started to run into people
who didn't have a meditation practice
that I really wanted to interview as
well and so I reached out I got in a
Twitter debate about the work/life
balance with Keith Raboy
it was a famous technology investor here
in Silicon Valley and we got into a
debate and he suggested I read the book
called the upside of stress and the
upside of stress talks about the upside
of stress which is essentially if you
reframe stress not as a threat but as a
challenge your nervous system starts to
interact in a way that's like really
beneficial yeah yeah have you are you
familiar with yeah yeah I love that
concept so cool yeah there's another way
to viewing that that Robbins Pro Tony
Robbins programs helps you program it to
people which is that you know when you
think about your heart racing before you
do something that you're nervous about
you think about it as exciting
interesting hacking something new and
challenging interesting instead of like
on the fear yep yeah and that's you got
it right in the body posture too because
that's what we do right we there's a
threat this is a threat and then this is
this is like I'm open this challenge
yeah yeah break okay so that was a big
part of this yeah and then so I'd end up
using that on that first episode like
use that challenge thing and like it
turned out to be a really good episode
really enjoyed it and and so then I just
and I fell in love with the process of
interviewing which I want to ask you
about how you why you started that and
getting to continue to do this yeah
let's do it let's so let's switch it up
are we ready yeah yeah yeah so yeah like
what first got you into interviewing
people insatiable curiosity interesting
that's a huge one also just knowing that
there's so many brilliant people that
need a platform to disseminate powerful
ideas and so then just wanting to just
go and talk to as many of them as
possible on a on a video switching
system that enables us to just
streamline what is it about the
recording process that makes it a better
conversation because I've noticed this
in my own interviews that something
about recording the conversation makes
it a more interesting more engaging
conversation for the people actually
having the conversation right Oh
interesting
oh versus not recorded yet yeah yeah I
think that's actually something that's
plaguing a lot of our world in a very
weird way which is that we have a we
have lots of thought-provoking
conversations with people that we don't
record so those are forever loss and
never get to inspire people be some
people
to tweet or Facebook or whatever
everything that comes to their mind and
that creates a fuckload of noise because
some people just don't think that that's
important signal for them to see so
there's kind of a a and B there with
that I've I've I've thought that the
purposely so trying to curate the guests
that come onto the program with a high
degree of vigilance with their impact on
the world as well as the calibre of
their ideas is one of those things that
tries to make it closer to signal and
further away from noise yeah and so that
and this is what got me really
interested in interviewing you was the
was you bringing on Alex Chen for the
show because many times he's the most
popular guest on the show really yeah
nervous then some people have come on
twice but he's three now Wow
yeah yeah I mean the the caliber of his
questions maybe it's just because of
also because of how many questions he
comes up with but it but also he is a
very unique individual as well so I love
to learn more about about what you
learned from interviewing him and stuff
like that yeah well a couple things one
of the things is yeah Alex kitchens asks
50,000 plus questions on Quora and now
he's just like still asking so many
questions one of the things that's
fascinating about him is I love that
that in the insatiable appetite that he
has and also the the degree of just not
worrying about shame and that's
something that's so fascinating it's
like he's just you know he's just gonna
go I'm where I'm just gonna go whoever
it is and just ask and say hey I might
not know something about I don't know
about this I'm gonna ask you this
question I don't he doesn't know that
people he's asking to which is great
like yes yes which has given me a bunch
of influence seeing him do his thing has
given me a kind of inspiration in order
to just like ask people questions and
not really care whether they answer or
not really care like because I know some
of them will answer their questions and
it's really I love like and and there's
something else you mentioned I think it
wasn't that interview with Alex Chen
about about how important the one-on-one
learning process is like I think it was
working with coaches but also just
interviews no problem so what is that
yeah blue to Sigma if you famous
psychologists figured out that
if you if a student has a one-on-one
mentorship with the role with a mentor
that they end up performing two standard
deviations past the mean of the rest of
the class so it's super important to
have a one-on-one mentor versus these
classrooms of 25 or 30 kids absurd so
it's really important to have one-on-one
mentorship and further it's not just the
authoritarian teaching style of a mentor
it's like it's like the mentor ask
questions like hey what are you
interested in oh I want to you have to
do something you can't do nothing you
have to do something so the kid gets to
pick what they want to do and the mentor
can help them be like okay you got
you're at a challenge okay how can you
work through this challenge giving them
the answers or anything the right foot
yeah interesting
yeah and that's actually gets into why I
started the podcast was I was actually I
was I was working with coaches and the
coaches were very expensive and then I
was like and I started interviewing
people I was like wait oh I can just
reach out to anybody one of my most
recent episodes was like I interviewed
somebody who's this coach - a lot of
CEOs and celebrities and and it's about
one of like five episodes where I've
basically gotten free therapy exchange
for for putting putting my whole life
out there and so it's been very
impactful and it's like interviewing
like it's amazing that the this process
of one-on-one where I can just kind of
dig into your knowledge base and stuff
yeah and then and then leave that as an
artifact for other product it goes well
I heard by correct yeah and it's you
only you have zero people listening then
one person listens then two people
listen then you have three followers and
then you have one person shares the
content and then two people share the
content this is the this is the only way
that it really good that it really grows
in its most grassroots style and it
takes time and it takes time the instant
gratification has ruined people's desire
to climb up a really tall slope and we
find the most meaning and purpose from
climbing up really tall slopes that
doesn't mean people should be
malnourished or or be barely afloat that
they can't even take care of their
health so we need to take care of some
of the social fabric things to make it
so that we can raise the baseline for
all
able to enable that creative flourishing
more effectively how we do that is a
complicated system that we're currently
exploring permutations of how to do
interesting and you had you had Andrew
Chen on the show right yeah Andrew yang
yeah yeah yes yes the blending yeah yeah
yeah and he's got some interesting ideas
but yeah yeah basic income or basic
assets are all different types of ways
of there's so many trials happening
around the world but yeah there's
there's going to be an interesting
technology transition that happens and
we got to figure out how to how to
properly make sure that people don't go
into more suffering but the seed the
seed of the child of the human mind
needs the nourishing that it needs the
love and compassion from the mom the air
shelter water food energy education
health care all these basic needs in
order for it to flourish and when
they're missing those nutrients the seed
can't flourish and then without that
flourishing and that trauma having more
kids birthed into trauma is gonna cat
it's gonna be bad Suzanne this is the
this is the key thing I've learned about
about trauma and particularly early
childhood trauma is that in an
individual who is traumatized and who
hasn't done the the healing that it's
the most important part is to get them
into a place where they feel safe and
until that safety is found there is no
possibility of going back and healing
that trauma and so that's the importance
of safe spaces but then the issue with
safe spaces becomes that even they
became can become a crutch where are you
because ultimately safety comes from
your own ability to to create a safe
space which you which one-on-one
teachers are really good at helping you
figure out basically you don't want to
get too close to coddling but you want
to give just enough independence and and
and and love and compassion for the
person to that's why psychedelic
psychotherapy works really well they
build a really long relationship with
the patient as the therapist and then
you add the psychedelics which which
helps them integrate the trauma
peacefully into their
yeah interesting I want to do it show it
I want to do a theme on that yeah
there's a lot of people from maps that
uh-huh
that you could interview to talk about
that cool yeah so what where did
simulation come from where did the the
name come from where did the idea for
this show come from yeah so all this all
these thought-provoking people and
conversations that we want to have when
we needed a show to have these questions
answered about you know how to update
the code of civilization across all
these different fields and stuff like
that and so the name simulation is it's
super important to run simulations and
this means like you know you see
civilization and you see it evolve the
way it did well what happened if you
tweak some of the variables and evolve
differently what if the earth was a
different size it wasn't eight thousand
miles in diameter what if it wasn't
ninety three million miles from the star
what if the civilization had different
organisms that evolved on at different
animals and plants and insects different
humans evolved in a way that we what if
we just waited for every seed to have
the nutrients that needed without just
having kids that were born into trauma
mm-hmm so there's all these ways to
think about simulations besides just
simulation theory thinking are we in a
simulation well because in a couple of
decades when we start running our own
simulations of civilizations I think
we'll quickly realize that this may as
well potentially be one then who I
whatever happens pre-birth and post
death is another very interesting
conversation are you just gonna you know
just take off the the haptic suit and
glasses when you die and you're like
damn I got to my highest level in that
life okay go to the next mission
whatever the next quest is so there's
all these different variations on that
on that word simulation and it says what
I got from that too was that you you
invite somebody on to the show and then
you get into their simulation because
all of us have a simulation running up
and then that adapts your own personal
simulation right yeah yeah that's really
interesting their code updates my code
their worldview updates my worldview
interesting that's what the updates the
worldview of other people that are
watching and that's why curation is so
important yeah because one concept I've
been working with recently is that as an
organism I can't
every environment that I put myself in I
was just you know and Soma and that is a
crazy environment I can't if I can't
influence how that is affecting me I
mean maybe I have some sort of control
over it but because most of my thought
processes are unconscious
I cannot say exactly how it's going to
affect me walking by people shooting up
heroin and stuff like that and so that's
why curation of and I don't don't at all
want this to mean like that you avoid
people who have mental health issues or
anything like that but there is
something to be said about like doing
that with a wise wide-open kind of thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah and the the what
eyes wide open especially means knowing
how to think critically about how a
human got into the shoes that they're in
because this is not something that this
is all roll of the dice you could have
been born to a mother and father that
were meth or heroin addicts and that
were gone all the time and we had to be
raised by foster care that we had to
just keep jumping to and from versus you
could be the child of Mark Zuckerberg er
Priscilla Chan you could it's not that
it's an this is not a this is not a
simple like I can just walk by and not
this is interconnected of every day you
can't be separate from it yeah yeah
which is yea really interesting
there is a there's a thought but it's
gone now yeah yeah you need to talk on
stress and creativity on this show sure
you want to hit that yeah let's do that
yeah okay what are the stresses that
face didn't doing this money money yeah
he's a big one
the like staying afloat like in the
creative process ISM you know why do
artists have to be starving they don't
we need to figure out and make a better
social fabric that makes it so that
yeah Elif is trying to do that that's
their mission is to basically make may
create and make it possible to not be a
starving artist I actually didn't know
that that was the you get different art
though you get you're gonna get
different art without the struggle
without that hardship I just want to
throw that in it's a very wealthy
artists are a lot different than stars
and so that I'd rather look at poor
artists work all day that some you know
privilege to pompous guy that paints
[ __ ] vases and flowers so you're
arguing that that suffering is a key key
element of making you have to meet it
halfway there has to be a way to be a
little more supportive of the creative
effort among all of us well and that's
what I've discovered a lot on the show
is that is that most of the most
creative people are creating from a
place of trauma that is a the creation
is is a natural like therapeutic way of
releasing that trauma and that's that's
they're they're not doing the art to be
famous they're doing the art because
something inside them needs to express
that something inside them needs to fix
the problems they see exactly yeah it's
a burden but it's the most beautiful
creative process at the same time you
wanna go and and and and travel and
experience different cultures and go and
and spend more time with your family or
watch a little bit more television or
Netflix or we'll do a little bit more of
whatever it may be go out with some
friends go dance with some friends or
whatever maybe mmm but you're stuck
building what your dreams are every
minute you spend away from building your
dreams and this is again this is the
whole hierarchical climb and and the
not only increase the impact of what
you're doing but you also want to
stabilize yourself financially you can't
stabilize yourself financially when
you're running around going out and
doing all that other stuff as well
absolutely so then there's that thing to
blend and so stress I'd say for you know
for me and I would be interested to hear
what you know what Rana has to say about
this but I would say that you know
within the process of the last year-plus
of building this it's definitely been
like how how can we you know just stay
above that at that point where you like
can can I can I can I make all the
expensive SAP in this month hmm so Ron
what about you for the role that stress
is played in our creative process well
it certainly doesn't have the same
amount of stress on you as it does with
me being that you know you don't really
work other than on this program to
generate any funds to finance the effort
so I don't think I'm the best person to
ask about any stress involved in this
creative effort you seem to be doing
okay you should be grateful that you
have a 52 year old man that understands
what we're doing here and you know
stress what are you gonna do about it
I've been dealing with it for years you
know this you know since 1998 when I set
out to do Fried Chicken it's been a it's
been a fight you know a creative effort
that's gonna promote community that's
gonna talk to young exceptional people
that are thinking outside of the box
it was totally against mainstream
narrative mainstream education and there
was a dark villain that I just couldn't
put my finger on it but I'm aware that
it's it was there it's been there and
it's still among us and it's right
around the corner tomorrow so stress
there's an element among us that doesn't
want things to
it doesn't want peace love and
understanding there's no money in it and
that's what brought I'm when both of you
were talking which is essentially that
it seems to be that there is always a
hero's journey to it like you can't
create without a sense of being up
against some sort of Sisyphean pushing
or block up a up up a hill over and over
again watching to come down pushing it
open again and like there's something
about that that seems unavoidable most I
don't think most people you know in that
and that's the problem with with what we
have today where we have this this
culture where it's just kind of like you
only see once you get up above that
above that area because there's so many
people out there not getting above that
area and there's so many people who are
just surviving and managed to keep long
enough towards till they've hit that
kind of that role and where's the time
to contemplate the cosmos to contemplate
existence when you got to run around and
scrape to get by and all that stuff so
the creative endeavoring is squashed by
stress and another maybe way to phrase
what we just talked about as well as to
think of if all the basic needs are met
you can summon anything you want
whenever you want as well as if you're
if you're if you're gonna live forever
yep mmm-hmm if you're gonna live forever
and if you have everything you want it
at the first thought that you have it
where is the motivation for you to do
anything and where's the beauty and
where's the beauty that mm-hmm if you
can just you know summon it so quickly
or and if you can just live forever mmm
is that good do you want to live forever
digitally to be able to go and
experience all different types of qualia
feeling and experience
can you answer that question auntie do
you want to live forever
Stewart certainly don't I'd I have no
interest whatsoever in living forever
yeah I was really interesting because
before I started on this whole
meditation you know going off for a long
time I struggled with that question a
lot because I have a lot of huge fear of
death and I think everybody has a fear
of death I don't you don't have a fear
to know I'm ready to go tomorrow but did
bring it on so bring that [ __ ] on and
she as graphic as you can possibly make
it did you have a fear of death before
did something happen
no I don't even even recall well
something happened but even before it
happened I just didn't give a [ __ ]
I really didn't you know my whole
objective any younger
time was to just live my life you know a
few people got hurt on the way including
myself and I would probably change that
but other than that it was of all about
pushing the envelope and knowing that
nobody ever dies anyway and there's a
lot more in life than you know what our
3d reality suggests so no I'm not afraid
of our will I ever be of death and so I
had that struggle of essentially like I
was pretty afraid of death and and and
then you see these people in technology
investors who are trying to create a
world where there is no death or where
well it should be immortal as opposed to
immortal because we can't we're not
gonna get the science to become immortal
we'll get the science to become immortal
which essentially means that we won't
die from old age but we can die from a
bus accident or something like that like
so so you've seen this and like how what
a you know if you're convinced that
you're not gonna die what a huge letdown
that'll be right if that never comes to
pass right but it's interesting and then
and then I did a lot of meditation
practice and a lot of
research and thinking studying into
Eastern philosophy and I still I still
have a fear of death of course but but
this this this there's a lot there that
can help because what is dying
what exactly is then when I die like and
if you ask that question to the core
it becomes difficult to find a solid
answer as to that you know like the
organism dies but then it gets recycled
right like yeah my life is far more you
know we already have immortality it's
already among us it's not in these
machines these bodies this meat puppet
that holds this soul
this whole human experiment even hmm so
I wouldn't I wouldn't sweat the fear and
get thing if you wanna you know I can
take you there after the show if you
have done with that you know take a gun
to my head too and you know be on the
other side see I told you you'd be like
how do we get back oh my god I don't
know
that's my imagination yeah the infinite
consciousness the infinite
interconnectedness of things as makes it
easier to not constantly not worry about
it you come contemplating it's very very
beautiful mmm we visiting death is a
very powerful experience over and over
again and also something else that I
think we were you know mentioning
earlier is the way that the way that you
know gratitude plays a role
it's a counteract the stress so you know
money was the first one that was brought
up and then there's like the other ones
right the other ones are you know you're
you're kind of getting into a process of
like these are novel stimuli and right
but repeat stimuli can be a little bit
stressful be a little agitating when you
have to take every single one of these
episodes after they're done and you have
to go and make a thumbnail and you
go and make the bio and you have to go
and make the tags and you have to go and
add the monetization marks and then you
have to go in them at the end screen and
then you have to go and do the same
thing on Facebook and then you have that
was YouTube and then you have to go and
do post it across LinkedIn and Twitter
and share it on Facebook and send those
links to the guests so that they can go
and promote it that process takes hours
yes and unless you have the money and
when you have the money you can hire
someone that you that believes in you
that you believe in them that you can
more easily you know work together on
there and you can potentially spend more
of your time on the creative side of
things so sometimes one can get caught
in that stressful process and then when
I get caught there I find myself doing
gratitude I'm really grateful for Ron
that's a good plan
yeah I'm really you know yesterday when
we were just you know chilling after
some shows you know I just told Ron how
just you know while I was reading the
end part of Esther's book and I was just
like like holy [ __ ] I came to me again
and I had to tell Ron again that the
only reason why the show has gotten this
far is because you've believed in it and
you've worked with it on me the whole
time we've been doing this the last year
plus I'm like the same thing with my mom
and my uncle right my mom and my uncle
have done a tremendous job at raising me
they get to this point and how they may
get here and so when my mom will be like
you know like you need some help right
now and I'll be like like we need some
help and she'll be like you know here's
200 bucks like you make it happen like
keep going keep making it happen you
know and you don't and you don't you
don't stop you don't want to you don't
want to to be real you don't want to be
you want to do want to be dependent you
want to be independent saying want to do
your best in tune you know it's not you
know pool and ass but you know we've
went out and emailed 200 people that
we've interviewed and been like yo like
we have a serious medical issue that we
need to take care of it and we need to
help paying this can we please have your
help and people will send us a hundred
dollars five dollars
five hundred dollars to help us you know
get through that that medical issue and
get moving so so the you know really
figuring out how to tap into a community
of people that believe in you and asking
them for you know will you become a 510
$50 a month patron can we count on you
every month to help out cuz then if that
number can increase that's kind of like
maybe a monetization on a YouTube or
Facebook you can rely on that a monthly
basis and that's when you experience
maybe less of the fluctuations and more
of the stability and that really helps
on things but gratitudes been a major
practice grateful free even waking up
grateful furthers a day grateful for
wrong mom boris grieving for the
community people that watch the show
before the guests were coming on these
practices and it's written up there on
that top line on our on our little
pyramid of fun fun writings that waking
up every day and having that gratitude
along with a little bit of a little bit
of stretching the body moving the body
around not just being you know stagnant
and
and immobile here on a desk but really
moving around these processes can help
one get through stress much more
effectively and then that helps with the
creative process when you're taking that
deep breath and you're being grateful
you're like I'm you know I'm in love I'm
in love I'm really grateful and and so
just the ecstasy of being alive well and
that's interesting too because that
could take it back to stress as a
neutral definition which is that in in
in bodywork we talk about stress is
essentially gravity is a stressor and
it's not positive or negative it just is
the the feeling of being on this planet
with this mass underneath our head you
know so and then exercise is a form of
stress like that is a form of stress on
our body but it's the form of stress
that our bodies evolved to deal with so
it is evolutionary rewarded and this is
why movement feels really good and if
anybody there doesn't feel good at
movement I can show you how to feel good
because every a lot of people come to
this idea of exercise is something that
should hurt and I went through a long
period of that which is and it doesn't
have to at all it should be like joyous
like in dancing when you feel that part
of your body just open up lay your hip
and you're like oh it's breathing it
feels great and the energies moving
through energy moves when you're dancing
and you're not worried about what other
people are thinking of you but you're
just moving your body yeah you know
that's one of the big things is it gotta
get rid of the perception of other
people impeding you from achieving what
you set out to do yeah people will get
in your way they shouldn't get in your
way of people that say they can change
the world like go and change it improve
prove the world that you can update the
code of humanity update the mental map
of humanity prove the world you can do
it and maybe you're gonna do for just
one kid maybe you're gonna do for your
family or your community yeah maybe
you're gonna be a moonshot idea you're
gonna impact all a billion of us but go
and do it
and that's that's a key thing which you
mentioned is is that a lot especially
here in Silicon Valley San Francisco is
this idea that you have to make a
massive impact change in order to affect
the world but you don't you there's
nothing better about creating a Facebook
as opposed to helping one kid is the
spectrum of a yoga teacher once taught
me which is transactional what we're
doing here is a transactional piece of
content I don't mean to say that this
conversation is transactional but I'm
saying that the that we're creating a
piece of content that is going to make a
small like a change in somebody's life a
small one maybe a big one as well
but then on the other end of spectrum is
transformational and that's what you get
when you get one-on-one work where you
can really kind of get that
transformation
so it's this and so you can beautiful
you can go anywhere on that spectrum and
transformational is actually sometimes
way way more impactful because there's a
if you're affecting one kid who's
growing up in a difficult situation with
not much money and you're giving him the
type of coaching that somebody really do
gets then you are making not only an
impact on him but if he has kids you're
making an impact on his kids and then
their kids and then their kids so it's
like throughout time you know exactly
yeah that is a very very powerful thing
to say is that transformational change
that we can help catalyze and someone
goes for generations and it's very very
powerful
we like to think about as different
colors on a color wheel like a moonshot
can be green and then helping someone
else out on a one-on-one level can be
blue there's like different colors on
color wheel
we definitely need all colors yep yeah
mmm yeah there's more past the stressing
creativity on simulation what are the
other ones that you want to ask
so yeah let's what is your definition of
creativity the definition of creativity
yeah it's it's hard I like I like you
know most most important I think for
people to say is the words I don't know
write those three words are such a taboo
I think it's very important to know how
to say those words from the short 26
years that I've synthesized stimuli
so here's another most people associate
creativity with art and writing and all
these different stuff but then there was
creativity in a business context there's
creativity in a thought I'm thinking I'm
thinking about it very very abstractly
right now I'm trying to yeah yeah I go
for yeah I'm thinking about it covering
all of that and more I'm trying
there's there's something beautiful
about the novelty that arises within
oneself about a situation that they're
in and it can be like you were described
it can be when you're you know when
you're working on something yourself it
can be when you're just talking to
someone else and you realize something
anything from when you're viewing a tree
and someone explains that there's a very
beautiful as above so below component to
the soil and ecosystems as there is to
the leaves that you maybe you have a
moment of awareness expansion you've
become more aware more enlighten let's
say spiritually awakened that those
moments can be called creative that that
not only was that a time of you
awakening and being creative but the
other person helping there or adding
their creative creativity to it as well
we like to talk about how everyone is
Korean everyone has the potential to be
creative a lot of our social fabric just
squelches that creativity we were
talking earlier you can't contemplate
the cosmos you can't contemplate the
tree when you're running around barely
staying low so you can experience some
creativity when you're running around
staying afloat but but and and and
everybody is creative and it's built
into our DNA to be creative because
we're all creating a simulation of our
surroundings all the time with our
senses were like when I see when I see
you I'm not seeing you I'm seeing light
reflect off of you and then my neurons
are taking that to 1/10 of what you know
what the light reflected on you is is
actually and then they're creating a
picture of it combining that all with my
sense of smell with my with my my my
tactile response and everything like
that and creating this picture inside of
my head that's a creation like yeah and
like and like every moment can be
considered creative and then thoughts to
like thoughts themselves like when a
paranoid a paranoid person is incredibly
creative like they are creating
everything all the times of tons of
alternative realities and possibilities
yeah Ron what are your thoughts on what
being creative means yeah I was gonna
say something not I mean granted
we all have the capability to be
creative when we come in but there's an
element and there has been an element
among us that we all can't be creative
you know there are other people that
just need to be told what to do and I
mean you're not now now we have to get
out of that mold but it served its
purpose
and hopefully we'll just have you know
less people on this planet and most of
us will be creative and all we've done
is just create a better world for a
small number of human beings you know so
the creative process
you know I've I've seen it maybe it's
still under attack I'm not sure but you
know people don't non creative people
don't like creative people or understand
them you know they listen to their music
they'll watch their films they'll
appreciate their art but when they meet
them one on one you know they may have a
different opinion so it kind of takes
all types and if you forfeit your
creativity you know good luck to you you
you know become a cop I don't know
there's a great piece of what you just
said about courage and essentially the
courage to become creative because that
it does require a lot of courage in
order to create something and then put
it back out there as well yeah how is
that as have you done any interviews
where you're just like well I don't know
if I could publish that have you done
that no even though even the worst of my
performances I because I and I think
there's a very important I think there's
a very important reason to that one of
them is because you want to be
completely vulnerable and honest with
like when we were first starting I was
[ __ ] I still am barely better than [ __ ]
you know I'm just barely better right
and so that's the point is to be able to
look back and admit like that you
weren't that good as an interviewer and
that the point of even those initial
ones wasn't even for me the points not
for me the point is for the guests to be
able to shine it their best and
communicate what they
and inspire other people with that
anyway so see yeah that's that's how I
feel about that interesting and then
there's more as well another question
well if you want to say something I've
another question of something that we
were talking about earlier they don't
wanted to bring up which was was really
interesting seeing you too
and and the relationship the co-founder
relationship it was really interesting
for me because I have had co-founders in
the past but I am now doing this on my
own for the past year yeah and something
about it is just like I have not been
able to ask anybody to work it's
something about has been mmm I just
needed to do this on my own and it's
been it's really interesting seeing
seeing this relationship that you guys
have but then also reflecting on how I
don't have that relationship and I don't
it's all inside my head like and it's
like and it's and it's like I can ask
people for advice and stuff like that
but I don't have what it what I see you
guys and there's obviously downsides to
that as well and there's positives to it
yeah yeah and there's downsides to what
I what I'm going through but also
positives to it too which is really
interesting yeah yeah yeah you go first
yeah you bring you bring up something
very important which is when you start
something you know usually you're either
trying to you know start it yourself or
find one person two people whatever you
can find to try and start it and put it
together and the dynamics between people
that are trying to put things together
can be very difficult to to figure out
and I think what we learned with you
know Esther just on the show with jiske
we love her a lot and her works very
powerful she has trick is her pedagogy
trick GRI CK trut you need trust you
need respect you need independence you
need collaboration and you need kindness
and when you have those five things
amongst the people that you're working
with on the projects you're I think much
more likely to succeed on them but
sometimes like psycho metrics are not
matching on certain topics like a really
good one again is to ask the person that
you're working with like Ron and I both
have a vision on like creative
warehouses that we really want to see
young people work in these beautiful
creative warehouses that have tons of
space for people to take
and playing come up with ideas and
execute and like if we did you got to
ask the other person like what's your
vision for what we're doing a year three
years five years down the line and if
it's not aligned you guys need to talk
about it because that's you get to talk
and so there's obviously also you know
benefits of having to HAMP two pairs of
hands or three or versus one you can
just keep going whatever so that's how I
feel Ron what about you relationship are
professional and I appreciate the
dynamic you know we're we're polar
opposites you know you were very kind
and loving human being we're you know
I'm more embattled bittered older soul
you know I said to Esther earlier that
you know I'm Allen's John Lennon where
he's you know Paul McCartney more
positive and I'm just a little more
negative but it seems to work
it was the yin and yang between us it's
it's actually great you know movie
material you know when we get to with
this you know stadium place you know the
story of us getting here is it's quite
interesting but what you had mentioned
early about trick you know we have that
except I'm a little shy on the K you
know kind
Aled but we do have each other's trust
respect independence we give each other
what was collaborative collaboration
yeah we take interest you know I'm very
much interested in what we're doing yeah
the stuff these people that we sit down
with are you know extremely fascinating
and you know I'm exactly where I need to
be so yeah we have a great relationship
I love you I love you too right so Ron
is also kind of on that same like it
depends on which he wakes up in the
morning to kind of the kind of thing
where Ron can he can he can be a little
on the more
schizophrenic we're comfortably
comfortably I don't know whatever who's
gonna wake up in this Ron Vargas guy you
know but it's possible understandings
without a doubt it's also it's also
interesting that Ron started from a
similar principle set as I did when he
was starting Fried Chicken like 20 years
ago Ron was also about talking to
children talking to community building
community wanting to inspire people and
so the fact that we're doing like a
little full circle with that except in
Silicon Valley he was doing it in
Peabody in Massachusetts so these kind
of first principle things is another one
of these things when you're when you're
talking to co-founders that what are the
first principles what are your most
first level values that you believe in
do you believe in building something
that makes society better and what is
that thing how are you going to build it
how do you see the future together and
stuff like that so that's a we yeah
that's that's a and it seems like an
element what I'm getting from this is
the ability to have deep conversations
or difficult conversations like you
probably should not be in the business
of creating anything if you're not able
to have a difficult conversation well
one needs to be exposed to that and
practice it and because it's like rather
than like running away because if you
can't handle it's like well how can we
baby step you to it you know there's all
these stories about the way that you
handle fear of heights or fear of
anything is that maybe like you baby
step your way towards water can you put
your finger in the water mm okay I'll
put my finger in the water how about
your foot can you put your foot in the
water okay I put my foot in the water
and so that's how you kind of like you
know baby step your way into something
that you may not be that great you don't
just run out sinking threes you you got
a do along ya period of practice and
mastery mastery is a very very beautiful
part of this
of this part of this process of creation
it was interesting when you taught me
earlier about me all with I didn't
actually know that they had a very deep
passion to enable artists to be able to
actually breathe and have space to they
could create that and it comes from
their struggle as well so they they
started about might be like 10 years ago
creating art out of trash and for about
eight years they were not making any
money whatsoever and they were starving
artists for eight years in Santa Fe
making really weird art in a place which
is known for its very like good art and
good like traditional art and then they
started making a lot of money and then
they're like we are going to make sure
that we start this whole enterprise is
going to make itself so that artists can
get paid for what they're doing love it
that's some beautiful story in first
principles we need to we need to
interview the founders of mouths when
they're coming through the Bay totally
we would love to do make that hat yeah
I've interviewed the the former chief
technology officer he would be I'm sure
he'd be down next time you see ok come
through they're all in Santa Fe um do
you have any other because we have some
questions but do you have one more are
you pretty good on your we've covered
the creative notes dress yeah I think we
got it yeah okay cool so on our end
sewer are we alone in the cosmos
interesting yeah I've read a lot about
this of course I don't know I tend to
think we are we are not just because the
size of the cosmos and the
the you know we're like we're here so
why isn't something else out there then
the question becomes why haven't they
contacted us and then maybe we're the
first ones who have developed technology
so maybe we're but you know I don't know
yeah and then this is simulation so we
must ask you are we in a simulation
[Music]
I think we are in a hologram I can say
that I think because each part
represents part of the whole so I have a
whole universe inside of me that
represents the universe outside as well
you do as well I think I'm relatively
sure that so I think there is at least a
hologram going on simulation I mean you
know I know the the the the theory which
is that you know if if we're starting to
make simulations and as we make these
simulations more powerful then there
might be life inside of those
simulations so which would mean that our
life is also probably a simulation
that's that's pretend so it's an
interest in theory I have no other way
to prove it it's a great answer and our
last question is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
for me right now it's driving across the
Golden Gate Bridge and it's like this aw
inspiring I just got a motorcycle and
every time I cross it it's just like
it's actually fearful it's like bringing
up a huge fear in me crossing that
bridge because all of a sudden I'm just
like shocked by the the the aw of living
on this planet and this beauty of like
meeting that ocean and driving across
this this this this Bay that's coming in
this little stretch of water that's
opening up this giant Pacific and then
once I get across then hiking in the in
the woods up there it's just something
magical about that like so yeah I mean
that's again I think that that question
depends on what they asked me yeah
but then yeah the first the first
reaction was love but but but but love
is not something that can be accurately
described in words once you've put a
label on that then it's like then it
becomes something different you know the
Bay Area is gorgeous and we're very
grateful that Silicon Valley evolved in
this beautiful part of the United States
and to is yeah yeah when it's very
interesting when you start putting words
on love it mm-hmm
change but it what happens you can't
describe it easily just it's kind of
like elusive it's like it's like trying
to grab water kind of but uh the love is
everywhere and everything it is that
infinite consciousness and that
everything and all that is his love he
beautiful but just sometimes so far away
from it and we got it we got to come
back to that mother or that mother that
loving energy and I think a key term
there is a realization because it's
always there but it's the degree that
the which we've realized it cracked yeah
in the moment how much are we connecting
to the everything yeah yeah sure what a
pleasure this has been yeah it's been
awesome
yeah thanks so much for coming on the
show yeah it talks about my pleasure
talking to us about crazy wisdom that
you're building we're very excited to
see where you end up going this is very
powerful stuff being able to interview
people about these topics absolutely
also yeah keep keep talking to people
like us and others that you're that
you're talking to on your interviews and
stuff cuz you'll get good so you'll keep
getting good stuff for the audience that
you're
for totally yeah and I'd love to have
you on the show again in the future yeah
it's nice because we get the rillette
video here as well you start using just
I got a do it even just the phone cuz
it's having video and posting that to
other channels is crucial you gotta do
it yeah yeah much love everyone thank
you so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you think about crazy wisdom
listen let us know what you think about
stress and creativity the relationship
between those things spirituality and
tech relationship between those things
the dynamics between Ron August and
Alan's sake on thank you very much Ron
for producing and directing we love you
very much support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in all
Stewart's links to crazy wisdom are
below our links are below as well
support us help us grow as well much
love everyone go and build the future
manifest your dreams into the world that
will see you soon peace
[Music]